ultimi giorni romani prima delle vacanze
prima che partono tutti quanti sto
andando a casa di gianni perché le basi
delle cose e in questi giorni mi sto
prendendo il tempo per pensare e
riflettere su una cosa cioè che l'anno
prossimo vorrei un pochino evolvere
ancora di più il canale ma parto
dicendo questo ci sono delle cose che
cambiereste delle cose che implementerà
ste delle cose che aggiungereste che
togliere esche toglierà o qualcosa vi
piacerebbe anche semplicemente vedere
all'interno dei dei video fa temere
sempre pericolosi o magari la sera
quando libero tranquilla letto mi leggo
anche dei suggerimenti che sono un
pochino più sostanziosi in modo da
cercare di venirmi incontro e sto
girando sotto casa il mio cugino adesso
però citofono e andiamo a vedere stanno
tanti anni ma manco mi rispondi
proponiamo tornare a settembre con calma
visto poco fa scusate solo io
che si fa si batte la fiacca
io sono per andarmi a riposarsi sto
parlando di sonno o non hai dormito
enrico guardarmi con questa falsa
guardami la faccia ma tu sei morto cosa
ha fatto questo qui è la serietà di
questo post con gianmario l'unico serio
che sta facendo la quale la verità quale
io mi faccio il culo fa chiudere montali
a lui arriva tutto fatto per fermo e
raniero te e pensa di fare qualcosa
aggiunge e poi prende email no no
gianmarco ti chiedo scusa sei bravissima
facciamo facciamo anche tutti quanti un
like per gianmarco e per il guscio di
quello che si forse è per questo che
lavori e questo è
cosa della summer edition una summer
edition di cucina nel secondo ma
riconosco che è stato la riconosco
capito ho capito ma questo è stupendo di
video un'ora e tre quarti di girato cioè
che usciva al cinema facciamo prima
certo casamenti mamma ma tu sei
praticato mamma cioè tu sei rimasto solo
e fa pure mia sorella giulia out
ok e poi ci siamo ordinati carne greta
oa uno speedy non solo uno spiedino che
questo tipo kebab carli con una magia di
questo se poi mi scuso in seconda sia
questo è quello che succede a casa mi
sono riproposto di parla dopo il lavoro
sopra una cosa da fare è lavorare la
cheesecake a quanti ne stiamo per il
momento tiago 5
l'oggetto è difficilissima ragazzino
avevo chiesto nell'ultimo cucina buttata
via arrivare a 100.000 nike per far fare
rico una sfida che va contro gli
stupratori dagli occhi di tutti di breve
link qui a partire dalla cartella cui
mettete un light mettendo un like perché
vogliamo far assaggiare enrico un piatto
già assaggiato qualcun altro per chi non
lo sapesse rico è pazzo terry non hai
fatto va sotto e di come queste gare
esattamente il tuo gradimento molto
molto vigile ok ma questo carico detto
problema con la saggiare piatti
assaggiati altri perché la moria di
accentuare l'aic non mi piace in asta
tornerebbe ti lascia dormire riposati
che avrei lavorato tantissimo mi ha
detto gianmarco medico ha fatto qualcosa
meno
qualcosina ricevo tutti la situazione
politica in italia come come la come il
mio a dormire si sta formando uno tu
dormi il profiterol fatto da giulia ci
sta anzi per il compleanno di mamma è è
un profitterol rivisitato la giulia con
crema di limone cioccolato bianco
mamma mia tutto questo io dovrei tipo
stare un po a dieta no perché non c'è
queste cose perché no andrò in spiaggia
vorrei solo dire né da una chance perché
con questo giudizio sia l'ultimo video
il tra programmazione al padrino di cosa
mi sta venendo di essere un po di tempo
quindi un po d'ansia gianni comunque tu
quando partirà il 5 agosto settembre a
buongiorno e ritmi la prendiamo il tuo
esempio non faremmo mai
quando parte arrivo dire che vuol dire
quando partì a [ __ ] documentario io
dovrei partire lotto teoricamente doveva
di ballo al medico come si mette gli
occhiali c'è questo qui sarà il tuo look
per sempre e questo il lato buono ma
cosa che studiato mostra londra la
portano qui si troppo lontano no non si
vede non si
che bel quadro troppi però mentre
dormiva te vi siete sfondati al
profitterol gogna vedere questo al tuo
pubblico fai vedere questo arriveranno
tre palline mi ha detto giorno al potere
rimangiata 9 12 in quest'estate io farò
ascoltate una settimana in grecia
qualche giorno in puglia una settimana
catania e una settimana a filicudi e
cosa fate voi quest'estate riuscito a
partire
lavorate e non lavorate sono curioso di
saperlo assieme una vacanza dai ricchi
ma scrocco veramente tutto ragazze ad
ogni modo io vi saluto ragazzi ci
vediamo in vacanza ciao ciao ciao
sì ci sono libero sono appena stato
contattato dal fattorino amazon che mi
ha detto che non ho trovato a casa mia
per una cosa utilissima la mia crema per
i ricci come faccio quest'estate senza
nome crema per i ricci midem ieri ci
sono veri sono con te di un artifizio lo
chiamo gli ho detto che lo raggiungo da
veri ricci dove la trama per i ricci non
esisteva sto per partire non posso fare
video mentre guido perché non si fanno
ragazzi ma devo assolutamente andare a
prendere la crema
ok c'è un semaforo rosso ragazzi devo
andare tipo verso tivoli per riuscire a
placcarlo ma io non posso partire senza
le mie care ma per i ricchi va
l'edizione più grandi contro pensassi
essere così stupido sacrificare la crema
per idc per andare a salutare quei due
pirla ce ne sono veramente cambiare le
priorità dall'anno prossimo ragazzi devo
andare a prenderla crema per i ricci non
dormiamo per favore alla guida tutti
odio e coperti anti no non ci credo mi
sono ri fermato proprio a due passi dal
semaforo ma la crema per i ricci la mia
crema per i ricci non si prende da sola
mi trovo davanti ai magazzini
adesso chiamare
131 no
diciamo grazie mille
grazie abbiamo fatta scusate io sono
perché insomma c'era anche se in un
parcheggio a caso saluto a porta di roma
però aspettate perdonate perché proprio
buio ma questa qui è la cara lalla devo
dire che cosa è l'unica crema terricci
super leggera anche quando la metto dopo
nome fa sembra gollum cosa qui la
mettete quei capelli bagnati coi capelli
non bagnati cioè ragazze siete pazzesche
e ragazzi cioè se anche voi volete
essere pazzeschi questo però comprato
pure su anno
quindi c'è poco pazzesca ve la lascio
pure il link può sotto sapere comprati e
influenze sono allora io voglio questa
camicia ma l'unica taglia è quella sul
manichino gliela strappo
allora che la miss ha regolato il
rapporto che sono stato a casa tre
fermate mentre armate ma dovevo comprare
da zara delle cose che entrano in
gioielleria rovinoso prato perché mi
sento difficoltà loro esagerato un po a
sorpresa accedendo ad esso sono
un'esagerazione continuo in questo
periodo stavo finalmente riuscendo a
essere equilibrato vi dico solo che ho
iniziato una roba che si chiama incisi
ditte incisivi vince cinesi è un modo di
mangiare in maniera intuitiva ho qui un
rvm che fa vedere che effettivamente era
tutto vero primo giorno di intuitivi
thing
oggi con questo termine quindi lo
chiameremo capire che cazzo devo
mangiare oggi perché tu hai bisogno di
compagnia per mangiare se sei fan
mangiamo dire non è fame rimborso na li
tenga perché devo essere costretto a
mano che si è abituata ad avere consueto
perché di costretti a mangiare sano fame
mia grazie a chi mi ha fatto scoprire
intuitivi di fatto questo panino enorme
mia intuitivi thing sta passando a
sfondare lo so perché ho condiviso con
voi questo breve montaggio ma inutile
dire che non è presente alcun
esperimento ben riuscito però è una cosa
che vorrei provare in futuro fatemi
sapere se vorreste vederla perché son ed
intuitivi ding spacca vorrei fare un
saluto alla vigna che sono meno un becco
fino a che non scende in sicilia e
quindi può farle e il giorno dopo questo
video sta già diventando troppo lungo ma
qui sono riuscito a vedere
ancora risenti niente volevo
semplicemente salutarti ci vediamo a
catania tra poveretto è quella quella
partita grazie a crederci ciao ragazzi
ci vediamo giovedì con questo video
molto importante per giovedì con questo
video punto importante per me da
domenica si inizia l'esame le 19 ma
veramente teniamoci è esatto